la dernière grande figure de la lutte
contre l'apartheid n'est plus desmond
tutu prix nobel de la paix pour la
justice raciale et les droits des lgbt a
fait de la lutte contre les injustices
et la corruption son combat de vie il
était connu pour être né fatigables
défenseurs des droits de l'homme
fait ch nous devons critiquer ce qui est
injuste
non équiterre et maury moral il a
consacré une grande partie de sa vie à
lutter contre le régime d'oppression de
l'afrique du sud qui brille mais la
majorité noire en 1986 l'homme en robe
mauve est devenu le premier archevêque
anglicane noir du cap et de
johannesbourg
à face
le pardon et la réconciliation entre les
blancs et les noirs étaient son cheval
de bataille
tout comme son ami nelson mandela il n'a
cesser d'importuner les pouvoirs établis
au nom de la justice et de l'équité il
s'est même opposé au parti de la
libération en afrique du sud au pouvoir
depuis la fin de l'apartheid comme le
gouvernement
notre gouvernement il vos cheveux d
appâter le coffre est pire que celui de
l'apartheid il a d'ailleurs présidé la
commission de vérité et de
réconciliation une nécessité pour lui
afin de tourner une page sur la haine
raciale et son influence transcendait
les frontières de passage au canada en
1984 il a demandé au premier ministre de
l'époque d'adopter une politique plus
sévère pour faciliter l'abolition de
l'apartheid cette rencontre a d'ailleurs
été décrite comme un tournant dans la
réponse internationale
ryan malone est ainsi devenu le premier
leader du commonwealth a imposé les
sanctions économiques contre l'afrique
du sud en 1985 et la visite de
l'archevêque pour défendre ses causes se
sont succédé au canada comme celle ci au
parlement ontarien en 1986 où cette
rencontre avec le dalaï lama vancouver
en 2004 pour pour moi c'était avec lui
l'enjeu je dois bien personnellement des
plus grands hommes que j'ai que j'aie
jamais rencontré
alors messieurs ordinaire avant tout
alors de joie
il était
toute sa vie et l'activisme de desmond
tout ne s'est pas arrêté là au fil des
ans il a mobilisé la communauté
internationale sur la justice climatique
la crise du darfour servi de médiateur
au kenya est offert son aide à gaza
jusqu'au bout il aura été un homme de
justice de droit et d'égalité ici daniel
quatre jours radio canada montréal